welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you've just
had your sex fix from Netflix then this
is the video for you throughout it we're
gonna be discussing 3-6-5 dni and I
won't even D&I that this is gonna be my
worst video ever the Polish film is
about polishing knobs but it also comes
with an ending that leaves a lot to talk
about so sit back grab your lotion
because we're going in deep on what we
think happens and how it could set up a
potential sequel obviously that will be
heavy spoilers here so you don't
anything ruined then now's the time to
use your safe word and go of the video
whilst you still can you're still
wanting to get into it then give us a
thumbs up to go ahead and make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into 365
days
okay so 365 days follows Massimo
tagliatelle the leader of the torah'
celli mafia group when Massimo isn't
getting brain on a plane he's on a boat
like t-pain and this movie is very much
one for the lovers of lockdown it's one
of those rare films that comes along
once in a generation that makes you
teach yourself how to clear your watch
history on Netflix and if you share a
firmly plan then chances are you're
gonna be getting some funny looks around
the dinner table come Christmas oh shut
up Maureen you watched it too Massimo is
very much a man that is obsessed with
women and no more is this shown in the
opening when he spies on one wandering
along the beach through binoculars
yeah he's literally stood there watching
a woman with binoculars on though they
should come as something he regrets as
his father is killed due to it he
obsesses over the woman that caught his
eyes and led to his daddy's demise which
leads to an interesting an interesting
story I will say now eventually he
catches up with this woman who we learn
is called Laura and who watches this
live-action adaptation of Beatty and the
Beast tells us that all you have to do
to get a woman to love you is take away
all of her options and leave her with
absolutely no
choice in the matter whatsoever yay love
Massimo tells her that he will keep her
as a prisoner for an entire year until
she falls in love with him and he ruins
her relationship threatens her family
and makes her his slave I'll admit it's
it's a bold strategy not one of I'd open
with but I've seen worse he tells her
that he won't touch her without her
consent but after just one week she
caves in and gains full Stockholm
Syndrome
so yeah set feminism back to the dark
ages
I'm surprised Emma Watson wasn't up for
starring in this Massimo plays all the
moves that you wouldn't expect but they
seemed to work for him really really
well he hooks up with a woman in front
of her are you in love yet slaps her are
you in love yet and takes it to a club
as the two star-crossed lovers slowly
fall for one another here she's grow by
another mafia member which leads to
Massimo killing him hey no one gropes my
objects other than me this causes a
mafia war between the two families that
has massive repercussions for the end
though Super Mario tells Massimo to
ditch to which he refuses to leading to
a big cliffhanger I almost called the
Robie were there but thought best not as
there's been enough objectification
going on in this video actually actually
that reminds me I must remember to let
my wife out her cage day now this
probably is one of the worst movies I've
ever seen but it's also one couldn't
really stop watching the entire thing is
all over the place whether it's the
constant language changes the character
motivations switching without making
sense or just the general wooden acting
it's completely terrible and amazing at
the same time the script makes 50 shades
of grey look like Ulysses and Massimo
makes anakin skywalker look like he's
got the same way with ladies as james
bond ders never before has there been
someone who's done it so wrong but
somehow ended up doing it so right but
he's so hot though it's a weird film and
I've got no doubt that some single man
that was trapped in his basement for the
majority of lockdown is contemplating
suing Netflix because somehow they stole
the entire storyline from his
imagination during one of his darkest
days it really is that bad
obviously Massimo can't be the bad guy
for the entire thing and they do have
defined
a convoluted way to make the to actually
like each other no matter how many
pictures of himself he has hanging up
don't worry brunettes it makes blondes
look stupid too
they're all about equality here at one
point in the film Laura almost ends up
drowning and Massimo saves her which of
course leads to him drowning him [ __ ] I
told you it was the worst video I've
ever made I actually loved the Wikipedia
description for the setup to this scene
as it just says when she wakes up he
admits he was scared she might not make
it and doesn't want to lose her and they
then spend hours having sex thank God no
other films are probably gonna be at the
Oscars this year because they lose to
this anyway Massimo slowly loses his
grip on Laura and he allows her to go
visit a family whilst he sorts out the
business back home after hearing nothing
from him she goes clubbing with her
friend Olga and runs into her ex Martin
who follows her back to her home where
Massimo is waiting around like Batman
Martin realizing you can't fight the
dark knight leaves and Laura initially
angry at Massimo forgives him after
seeing the wounds from the Mafia war oh
you you were just killing people that's
so sweet
the next morning Massimo proposes and
Laura says yes because who wouldn't want
to marry a man that keeps women captive
against their will she also finds out
that she's pregnant and with a friend
Olga goes to try on wedding dresses
without Massimo the film ends with Luigi
finding out that due to the fallout from
their gang war that Laura has been
marked for death
Mario goes to Massimo but it's too late
to warn Laura as Massimo loses phone
signal with her as she enters a tunnel
maybe none of this would have happened
if you'd not let Massimo enter your
tunnel I'm alright now there are a lot
of implications over this with the main
one being that Olga Laura and the pair's
unborn child have been killed however
due to the speed at the police show up
and lock the area down I doubt that this
would have happened as the Mafia would
need to get out of there quicker than
Laura should have got out of Massimo's
house when she had the chance
instead I actually believe that she's
been kidnapped by the group and will be
held hostage the final shot of the film
lingers on a boat for a very long time
so is possible that this is where she's
being held 365 Danai is actually based
on a book by Blanca Lipinski that it's
the first of a trilogy just in case you
didn't think it could rip off Fifty
Shades any more than it does the second
book 10 days in which translates as this
day and are definitely pronounced wrong
has laura taken by the mafia rivals and
we actually learned that massimo has a
twin brother called Adriano Adriana was
not in the first film as he studied in
Britain and lived there for the events
of the first book and August starts a
relationship with them but you can
probably guess that they swap to see if
anyone notices absolutely weirdos I tell
you cheering her kidnapping Laura falls
for the new people that have taken her
captive most notably a man called nacho
who she too gains Stockholm Syndrome for
hey Massimo what you call a girl that
isn't yours
nacho girl I gotta go on that did that
does deserve a thumbs up now Massimo
eventually manages to get her back but
this causes a gang war between the two
Don's that makes everything escalate
further also Laura's heart is torn
between these two complete and utter
Psychopaths so you know it really makes
for an interesting dynamic now the
events of the first book are slightly
different from this film with some
things happening at different times and
them ending slightly differently I don't
think that the book ends on the
cliffhanger but I don't know if that's
true as I've not read it but I did read
about it on Wikipedia which is the same
so yeah we do we do know it does change
a bit I'm guessing that because of this
they will likely follow the framework of
the second book but there is a
possibility that they will change things
up I would hope that they ditch the twin
brother thing but hey it's not exactly
that this film is trying to do something
new but yeah
keep your eyes out now before we get
into the rest of the video I just wanna
let you know we're giving away a free
copy of the MCU infinity saga to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
being with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the movie in the
comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of July in a Cell be shipped
out from the interval gets the price
it's the best of luck to everyone
takes part okay so what did I think of
the film overall this is low-key just
like something you would get on the hub
except the story's not as good and I
don't think the acting is quite as good
either there are obviously a lot of
things wrong with the movie in terms of
the way that it portrays women and so on
but Twitter doesn't seem to be
complaining which is weird because that
that's the platform that got mad because
Sean Connery slapped a woman on the bum
in Goldfinger about 60 years ago now
the movie is terrible terrible terrible
terrible that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't watch it obviously you're
gonna have to make sure your parents are
not only in the room but you should
probably wait until they're five miles
away and also make sure you smash up
your TV after it so that no one sees
that you ever watch this thing 365 days
probably deserves a one out of ten and
also a ten out of ten at the same time
because it was the worst film I've seen
in forever but it's also one that you
just have to watch I have no idea what's
going on anymore but you watch this film
obviously if you're over 18 I don't want
anyone blaming me for ruin their
childhood but yeah just what a strange
film but here's to the sequel obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
film and what you think happened at the
end column below and let me know and if
you enjoyed this video then please drop
a thumbs up and make sure you check our
breakdown of de5 Bloods which is gonna
be linked at the end it's not it's not
as intellectual as this review but you
should have fun with it and if you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early gonna come chat - so after the
show either follow us that heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below huge thank you for
sticking with me till the end
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you
[Music]
[Music]